we are giving away memberships someone
who goes by gr on our YouTube channel is
sponsoring six memberships these are
genuinely free memberships gr is paying
for them for one year for six people
here is how we're going to give these
away pad I think you're going to like
this I hope you're sitting down gr is
known for his incoherent ramps on
YouTube live streams and these aren't
hate Reata cramps they're just
incoherent okay so the content contest
will be to create the funniest gr style
ramps which Pat and I will then judge
and giveaway six membership so here are
two examples of G ours a super chat
rants during YouTube live streams
they're not hatred mail okay here's one
example PAC PZ take it from the top
bring us to the progressive pastures of
green emerald utopia science fiction us
to a trump 'less world love gr here's
another example of one of these bizarre
gr YouTube rants quote it's time bonus
show or Co me flow don't own up to we
who called that session testimony just a
session full of old baloney
stanky like Trump the nasty face so
orange he match prison jammies
uh I can't make heads or tails out of
any of that yeah I never knew that
something could be so eloquent and
poetic well at the same time being
completely incoherent
yes devoid of all meaning so anyway the
idea is create something similar to that
about a paragraph and the idea would be
that the funnier it is and if this ties
in you know jokes from the show Trump
related stuff cop feffy is in right now
Sean Spicer in the bushes go at it from
whatever angle you will angle you want
go to david pakman.com click on contact
us send in your gr style rants and the
subject should be incoherent rant
contest okay then we will know that it
is an entry and we're going to give away
six memberships courtesy of gr I take it
that David Pakman show employees are not
eligible for this contest that's right
if you want memberships you need to do
what Lewis did who at one point I think
2.5 million memberships oh yeah - his
name that's exactly right and yes david
pakman show staff and their families I
should say are not allowed to
participate in this ok so create your
own rant get a free membership it's got
to be in the style of GR david
pakman.com click on contact us
title it incoherent rant contest